right now the san francisco giants
baseball team major league baseball team
are going to wear rainbow colored hats
for pride month they're gonna major
league baseball as you know american is
apple pie
america's favorite pastime relatively
conservative probably the most
conservative professional sport
they're going to dress up their players
in pride flags
to celebrate i don't know transiting the
kids or something right is that
do you think the fans will like that i
don't think so i say this is a baseball
fan do you think that the players will
like that i don't think so
corporations like that the radicals who
run those institutions like that but i
don't think the majority of people
get all that into it i don't think when
you drive around this country you'll see
a lot of american flags and you'll see
some rainbow flags and you'll see some
blm flags but i think still the majority
of americans don't identify
with those radical leftist symbols so
they're pushing and they're pushing
they're trying
to to create that that sense
of democratic popular support but they i
don't think they really have it yet
raises a lot of questions too what if
you're a muslim baseball player
and you say you know i'm actually not
cool with this stuff
are you are you allowed to not wear the
hat what if you're a jewish baseball
player what if you're a christian
baseball player
what if you hold a different view of
sexual morality
what if you hold a different view of
human nature even you know who we are
what makes us up
no you will be religiously coerced
by the liberal regime also also known as
our democracy you know the left always
talks when they
as angelo cudavilla the the great
political theorist writes
when they talk about our democracy
they're usually talking about their
oligarchy well what about it what about
the players who object to this sort of
thing they are going to be forced
to embrace religious
and sexual views and moral views that
they might not hold
okay i don't think it's totally
effective though
i think they know that the majority of
people don't don't go along with this
stuff
oh hey you nice to see you i wish i
could see you
more often i wish i could see you more
reliably
and the way that i can do that is if you
ring that bell ring that bell
subscribe like that way you will be able
to get the notifications
head on over to apple podcast spotify
google play stitcher
myspace xanga awhile instant messenger
subscribe
to the audio podcast the michael nelson
leave a five-star review we'd really
appreciate it
i'll see you next time and i'll miss you
until then
[Music]
you